this is a 74 Alfa Romeo GTV
it is an Italian car I would say it's
the grandfather of the sports cars that
we have today came in the 2.0 option but
it was agile and it was an attainable
sports car it's still this but this old
girl lacks in Horsepower she makes up
for an agility it's a classic piece of
art if you walk around the car they
don't make cars like this anymore to me
even the door handles or the front
grille they're moving our pieces orange
and black is definitely Khan's colors
and I'm really attracted to the older
cars these are like old boys so you know
they're about 50 years old I'm the same
age so I feel like it's my
responsibility to take care of them and
make sure that they don't break down
like I am you know you still know how to
drive
what do you think